big swish big swish nick swisher here on
the set good to be back guys doing
alright our energy levels just went
through the roof
swish or spike guys you do a good roll
ha are you gonna go putt you gonna go
putt a little bit you know I feel like I
need to get my game locked and loaded
you know wow look at all these sponsors
you have here yeah Callaway brother
Callaway guide to Callaway bro that's
right that's the way we're rolling it
all right swishes here what are you guys
checking about today well we just
chatted with cube about LeBron coming
and he was really excited he well I mean
as excited as cube can get speed yeah
he's one speed show did you just drop it
is that it that's it Nick Swisher won't
be on big Fox tonight right you're gonna
be on Fox tomorrow tomorrow Saturday
okay all right Nick Swisher is here on
the Rich Eisen show we will be back with
with swish and everything involving
major league baseball in this man great
to see you brother
you got that's next year on the Rich
Eisen show I do want to tell you about
the Honda fourth of July sales event
you've got is your baby arrived yet or
what yeah man we're good yeah we're up
there to push him for three but what do
you mama says the gates are closed have
a great night and 10 months later whoops
I was going to say should you require a
minivan
there's the Honda Odyssey for you we're
actually thinking about minivans dude
the functionality of a minivan is off
the truck the Honda Odyssey is something
you got to check out right now at the
Honda fourth of July sales event I I
will be there it is on the screen right
there that Honda Odyssey is all sorts of
awesome your kids can get in and out
themselves when they're old enough
should you open the gates for more this
room for more you know what I feel like
would make that in amazing cars I feel
like if we if we blacked out the windows
we turn it out the window
you know but just a great deal on the
Civic the politicians on that thing
available Honda sensing in all models
although I don't know if they're sensing
for what NICs talking about hurry it's
your local Honda dealership for the for
the black out the ribs it would be
amazing if the Vans rocking alright
we're back for about 80 seconds the
breath of fresh air that is Nick Swisher
here what would you say about a mixture
of iron and baby lotion was well yeah we
were we were talking about handshakes
you know I mean obviously huge fight
coming up on Saturday the ochen Cormier
which is gonna be an amazing fight yeah
but I'm saying the first time I've ever
met Ray Lewis yeah you know once you're
in his presence you know like he's a big
big man yeah you know me I'm like all
over the place my god Man Ray Lewis
brought Nick Swisher nice to meet you
and I come in like with this firm like
over-the-top handshake right and he went
like this and when I hit his hand it
felt like a mix like saying like iron
yeah but then like baby lotion to my
hardest handshake ever is Adrian
Peterson really yes do you know how when
they put the cuff on you to have your
blood pressure taken you feel like your
arm pulsing yeah that's what his when he
shakes your hand that I mean just comes
in and then his hand is so big it's like
he's shaking with my feet and that's why
I can't believe any time I see him put
the ball on the ground I'm like how the
hell did that happen
possible vice meathooks all right Nick
Swisher is here lots to talk about with
swish when we come back bro
he's got 12 seasons and major leagues
under his belt now part of the Fox
Sports baseball world is special advisor
to the New York Yankees himself and one
of our favorites good to see you Nick
Swisher Manson ah you know it's an honor
to be here my man I need to start doing
this more often Jill I have way too much
fun whatever you do so before we get
into the insider stuff the last time you
and I saw each other was in the lobby of
an escape room Oh correct an escape room
I was invited to a birthday party for an
escape escape room and we show up it's
like me and Suze and five other couples
and who's there but Nick Swisher and
your lovely wife Joanna Garcia yes at
the time and but you were separate we
thought we were going honest I thought
oh my god I'm going into an escape this
has now kicked up about 15 more notches
when we were part of a separate party
yeah what is it like being in an escape
room with Nick's ah you know what I'm a
team guy feel like I thrive in team
situations okay I may not be the
smartest but I'll give you all the
effort I got everything I got I'm gonna
give you but sometimes I might not pan
out as well as others motivator but
motivator I love it so it's interesting
we were talking an hour or 1 of this
show that the Nationals get swept by the
Red Sox yeah they've got a team meeting
reportedly Max Scherzer airs everybody
out and then they fall down 9 nothing to
the marbles hey we came back and won
that's what I'm saying to me we were
well I was watching the game just like
you were right and any time you have
that public of a players only meeting
this obviously you you'd like to think
of what went down in that locker room
and I think at that point in time when
you have player meetings you find out
who the leaders on the team are
obviously when we were in New York and
we had any players only meeting which I
don't even know if we did but if so it
was few the first person stands up was
Derek Jeter so I was interested to see
that then a guy like Max Scherzer was a
guy that stood up you didn't
you're much about what Bryce Harper said
you didn't hear about how he stood up
and said things and and I think there's
a lot of things swirling around him I
feel like there's a lot of he was taking
ground balls at first base the other day
that makes no sense to me I feel like
there's just a lot of things going on in
in Washington and obviously the one
thing that really stands out for me is
my mad Dave Martinez has been stressed
and to get that win last night the way
they did Trey Turner having an all-star
year man we got to get him to that game
he's one of our premier players but to
see that sort of come back I ain't so
great to see because after the game Dave
Martinez was looking at the media like
mmhmm yeah I told you you know I told
you our guys we're gonna step up we're
not gonna stop fighting we have 19 but
down nine nothing the Marlins of all
time I know exactly Jeter's Marlins
Mattingly's Marlins and you know but
what does go on in those meetings and
and why does something get out if it's
players only how does something get out
yeah that's what I'm saying I mean it's
supposed to stay in there right so does
somebody like Scherzer get pissed that
it got out or maybe he's the one who's
like whispering well I think he's
probably excited cuz it sounds like it's
his team and and and that's the great
thing I mean he's been the one
consistent thing the Washington
Nationals have had for years upon years
I look at guys like a Stephen Strasburg
who every time he takes the mound it
seems like he's dominant the problem is
you just can't get him on the mound as
much it just kind of seems like when he
pitches a good amount of the season then
the national go to the playoffs but
maybe this year's not the Nationals year
maybe this is the year that it all kind
of starts to crumble down I mean
Zimmerman's been hurt they've had a lot
of guys banged up the back end of the
bullpen is is is pretty good but what
about giving love to the Braves what
about what they've done what about the
love the gabe kapler and and the
phillies are doing I just think the the
NL East is a better division because of
those two teams and and I think it's
gonna be a struggle for the Nationals to
get to the plate to the BOCES well when
you got Nick Swisher somebody like like
Harper struggling he's hitting you know
sweet he's hitting less than his weight
right now yeah do you think these
impending free agency is weighing on him
what do you think is yeah you know what
I mean I've only been through free
agency one
and obviously not the level of Bryce
Harper but it's a stressful time because
you you want to be a team guy you want
to win but you're also thinking about
your future and and and where you're
gonna be and at the time you know I mean
I was married I was trying to figure out
you know where you know Jo and I were
gonna go things like that I mean
obviously Bryce is in that in that same
situation I just I don't like the things
that come out when Scott Boras is
telling the world why Bryce Harper is
bad because of shifts well everyone
deals with shifts so I think when your
agent starts coming out to try and
defend you that's when things start
getting a little haywire he said the cop
borer said that the shift is what's the
word that he used can you look it up
Chris I want to make sure that we get
the exact word about Bora said of the
shift day he's basically said it's
biased against lefties yeah there's no
doubt that that is by that that it
definitely for left-handers it's Bob but
for right-handed hitters it's not nearly
as restrictive yeah I mean I remember
that I totally agree with that that
statement is 100% sure Jason Giambi who
was one of my favorite human beings on
the planet said that was one of the
reasons why he his career started to end
was because of that shift I mean you
lose a lot of batting average points
because of that now the other thing is
Bryce Harper's pulling the ball to 20%
more clip than he ever has in his career
so I think for right now with where he's
at average wise I think he's really just
focusing about power I mean it just
looks like he's taking some hammer rips
dude every time he gets up there to the
plate because they're struggling he's
trying to get things going right I mean
they've moved him all up and down the
lineup uh the kids talent is absolutely
phenomenal I just want to see him put it
back all together
Nick Swisher here and the Rich Eisen
show Honda insider report I hate the
shift I hate it I you know and I you
know we had AJ Hinch on the show and I
asked him if there was a rule to get rid
of the shift would you have a problem
with it and he said absolutely I would
that it's my job to get some people out
and that this is the way that we're
playing and basically hit him where they
ain't cuz I said but I don't want as a
fan to pay to see Bryce Harper go the
other way bunt
he's like when he can hit a home or the
other way to correct and but I just
can't stand seeing and it is mostly
left-handed hitters correct yeah better
he
baseman's playing halfway back in right
field yeah and then and then when the
the he hits it up the middle the the
third base makes fielding yeah okay you
got to remember man so only because I'm
retired now and I'm looking at the game
in a whole different light if the game
is going to continually evolve and
analytics are going to continually be a
big part of this game you have to evolve
too so now if I have a percentage of an
advantage just like I would do if I went
to Vegas
whatever game I feel like I have the
percentage advantage that's the game I'm
gonna play right so if I feel like I
have an X percentage better chance of
being successful obviously I'm going to
take that chance because even on the
media side of things when we see a
manager make a decision and it doesn't
work we question that and so now I think
the gut manager in the game is gone I
feel like because if he says like hey
man I made that decision because of my
gut then you know on the media side of
things we're really gonna get after him
because there's so many statistics
there's so many numbers in the game now
that tell you that's why these that's
why every who these Ivy League grads are
coming into our game and just and in my
opinion I think making it better I mean
I have aspirations of being a manager at
some point in my life you do so I think
for myself is I have to stay up keep up
with the Joneses too you know like you
got to keep up with everything because
like I said as long as it evolves then
we have to evolve as well so then how
did how does the those numbers get
downloaded to you as a player I mean
does it fill your head with a bunch of
garbage when you really have to go up
there and talk about feel or just know
it yeah pitchers gonna do and you know
totally mad and you know what the
situation is it's one out you need to
get this guy over I mean so much stuff
that's in your head as a hitter to begin
with already well I think it's your job
as the athlete to be an athlete I feel
like sometimes we can see guys that get
a little robotic with their movements
maybe because they're thinking about
stuff and like you're saying I mean
being a special advisor and getting the
opportunity to work with the younger
generation yeah that's also an awesome
thing because these guys sometimes they
it's definitely an information overload
because I back when I was in rookie ball
and a ball a scouting report what was
that we didn't even know what that was
we didn't even know who we were facing
half the time so I think just in general
there is an information overload but I
think it's your job as that player to
pick the things that work for you and to
help improve your game
them what makes somebody like Aaron
Boone work okay now again you're
somebody with 12 years in the league
right I don't know how many Aaron Boone
has right around the right around there
spent a lot of years in the booth yeah
you're spending years now totally trying
to you know get cutting your teeth
beginning for a couple years now doing
horses TV how does how does Aaron Boone
work in a dugout where somebody like you
with managerial aspirations right and
can learn translate that yes you know
that without riding the bus in the minor
leagues oh there's a man oh you know I
think that's kind of where the games
going right now I mean there's five
first-year managers in the league this
year and there's I think there's three
guys that have never had managerial
experience there ever right but I think
now it's a little different because of
the analytics the the guys in the
computer room are going to tell you who
has the better advantage of succeeding
that day right and obviously you play
each game for the game that's what
you're trying to do sure so now it's all
about being able to relate to your guys
being able to motivate 25 different guys
25 different ways for 162 games season
the couple things that I've taken away
from Aaron Boone and I've been able to
spend some time with the guys in spring
training as well as make a few
appearances in New York over here the
last month yeah this cat is cool bro
like he is so chill and to be able to be
the manager of the New York Yankees you
have to do a couple things well you have
to handle the media well yeah but she
has done a tremendous job and you got to
put up W's and he's been able to do that
obviously I haven't been in that locker
room each and every day but to watch how
he's gone about his business in a first
year setting even earlier in the year
when Giancarlo was struggling he didn't
stress out he wasn't saying man I'm
freaking out I feel like I look at him
and then I look at a guy like Dave
Martinez and it's been it's kind of been
a tale of two different stories
obviously the Nationals haven't played
up to the way they have Bruni's team has
played up to the way that they are
supposed to so I think for him that he's
been cool as a cucumber man and he's
handled the media absolutely
phenomenally man as a Yankee fan and
it's kind of an employee I could not be
more honored to have him as our
and then there's Cora in uh in Boston
right I mean that tremendous job I mean
the Red Sox are 30 over for the guy
who's never really had the managerial
but that's I'm saying I think it's all
about being able to motivate guys being
able to get guys to show up to the
ballpark and play every day
the Honda inside a report again brought
to you by our friends at the Honda
fourth of July sales event that's still
going on it's still the best place to
get a great deal on a new Honda like the
Accord Civic or fit so head to your
local Honda dealer today for a sizzling
deal on a Honda you will love we'll take
a 60-second break come back and one of
those appearances you made was at the
Baseball Draft where you made an
announcement this is fantastic for fans
did not see this or hear it and don't
know what Nick and I are talking about
this is fantastic bro we're back in 60
seconds
DirecTV special coverage of the
Wimbledon Championships is still rolling
in channel 701 through 707 all the way
through to July 9th six channels of
coverage throughout the tournament plus
a mosaic channel and interactive
features video highlights of the top
players and matches every day that's for
broadband customers only there's a match
guide with current scores and results
for the entire field to order DirecTV
call one eight hundred DirecTV one eight
hundred DirecTV I wish there was by the
way I would pay to see a Wimbledon
channel with Nick Swisher you calling
tennis what would that what would that
set what would that sound loud it would
be loud there's no doubt about it I've
been to one I went to the US Open when I
was with the Yankees back in the day New
York yeah and I was lucky enough to ban
part of the Lacoste box and Joe had to
remind me multiple times this isn't a
loud event this is a very very
gentlemanly sport and you can't be as
loud as you are so I really struggled
but I don't know I feel like me and
Johnny Mac dude we've crushed life due
to the booth for sure you you I would
love to listen to you do it and
Wimbledon just so so when the umpire
says quiet please they could have said
quiet please Knicks yeah we're single
out one guy he's sitting about halfway
right here you know so now you have you
have
I guess a habit occasionally of
punctuating your sentences with the word
bro oh yeah I don't know how that
started man I'm originally from West
Virginia
I write which is shocking she like have
it this kid just get started off as a
redneck you know and they're like
evolved myself I guess okay but yeah bro
is just kind of been part of my thing I
don't even know how it came in there so
just every now and then you'll just bro
like you even punctuate your text your
text with the word brother or bro I mean
see you legit you're legit legit bro
so so when the Yankees put you front and
center to announce a draft choice at the
baseball dress right this is just on
this is one of this is awesome just roll
it this happen stuff everybody I'm Nick
Swisher and with the 61st selection of
the 2018 Major League Baseball Draft the
New York Yankees select Josh bro a
catcher from a clinic Community College
Waco Texas Chicago Cubs have the next
selection it was it was an older crowd
guys like Tommy Lasorda on Freddy Lynn
bo Jackson and you know I know a little
bit but I'm like guys you have no idea
what's about to happen right now I'm
about to blow the roof off this place
it was unbelievable because Brian
Cashman david APPA high up and higher
from the yankees absolutely we're
rolling on the ground when this draft
pick came into be you know to be on the
board like please it's spelled bre aux
correct ed pert but pronounced so when
you're in the back when you're in the
back you have this to this board right
and it tells you who the pick is and
then they hand you the card and you walk
out so it says josh CR EA XR u actually
was yeah and so I'm looking around I'm
like how do you say that and they and
the lady was like bro
yes Nick yes I'm very serious
[Laughter]
unbelievable we had two great picks at
that first day but that won't do rolled
out it is in it you know crime you never
do that for the Yankees it's a job I try
to take a lot of pride in so I try not
to make it like a funny thing the
glasses on sharp suit cleaned up you
know got me man I couldn't believe it
what I really wanted to say was y'all
won't believe you guys won't believe
what this guy his name is brawler can't
believe part of man so great and by that
I mean your last name and also bro just
oh wow you are something else now you
said you've done what to your your house
what do you do see yes so me me and some
of my friends we were trying to figure
out a way to kind of get ourselves
moving again and just kind of get
ourselves a little bit more back in
shape okay so okay good thanks man
trying to you know just keep trying to
trick them you know what I mean
everything above the desk that's pretty
much what we trying you need to see
these down here for Chad you know sighs
so our garage I kind of turned it into
like a gym you know I've been really
reading a lot on longevity and just
trying to someone live to be 120 man so
I feel like if I want to do that I got
start now sure so we turned it into a
kind of a gym and so me and my friends
on Tuesdays and Thursdays we get about
six or seven of us in there man and we
circuit train for about 45 minutes to an
hour and then after that I've got I've
got a I've got a sauna in there I've got
a hyperbaric chamber if you need to
recover so I'm telling you but I can be
your guy I can be your trainer to get
you ready yes world record speed I'm
talking about Nick this is what I'm
talking about you guys over just for a
session okay you should do just was wise
and what have you called this place ah
swish your sweat shop swish also SS
cubed sq
s cubed swishes sweatshop yeah okay it's
great can week so we'll come by
can we bring like oh yeah I feel like
you guys me I feel like you need to be
part of it you might experience this
sounds like steinbrenner dollars at work
sounds like steinbrenner dollars at work
a thousand percent yes sir okay first
rate first class always okay
always it's a transform garage you know
so sorry I mean we get it in there yeah
okay this is good for you rich you need
to start training and taking this
seriously you sound like my wife now I'm
saying I'm hard we want what's best for
you to the next level right five six
could happen if you just trained a
little wishes sweatshop yeah I'm gonna
run out for tea bro yeah bro stretching
you out pregame you know we gotta get to
make sure we get the right suit you know
make sure that stretch abilities pretty
good okay if that's a word know that it
now is liability aerodynamics okay let's
go I like it all right so you got that
going on and then you're on what so
what's on Fox tomorrow which games yes
we got the Braves in the Brewers which
is a great series great to first play
statements going into the break and
ellas totally won it's crazy man these
we were talking the other day that
there's an odd card game for the
American League One team is gonna be
hosting a winner go home game with a
hundred if not a hundred and five wins
yeah and there's gonna be a hundred win
or 105 win team going on the road for
that game it's crazy I feel like that
that wild-card game has really really
made things interesting coming down the
stretch I mean obviously you seem like
team kind of run away with the division
so it obviously gives us something to
talk about late in the year and I just
think that game it's so tough because
anything can happen in one game yeah and
just you never know but I feel like for
teams that might be on that 88 90 game
fringe sometimes they get lucky enough
to pop in there okay so who are you on
with on big Fox tomorrow oh it's me the
icon Chris Myers oh yeah you know Chris
I mean he's got his way
I did I do I'm here you're there you're
not me I'm not you my kid because I care
share haircare products with does have a
lovely salad Bravo and Detroit Dontrelle
Willis male super cool didn't reach out
because we did like a funnier dog pitch
fraud it was on bro he's got way energy
man super heightened by the way you
might need to get a bigger chairs a big
man
okay that's big man coming in here okay
he's a warrior France who's he's big
basketball okay so swishes sweatshop
we're gonna stop by yeah you come back
anytime man I had a beautiful lovely
absolutely I appreciate y'all have me
all man I mean this is this is easy
good it's come down best was it easy to
get from the sweatshop to here or was
there a little bit Oh sir hey people are
taking their their vacation days you
know driving in LA its money right now
guys okay you need to go 30 minutes man
it doesn't matter beautiful so we're
perfectly okay so I guess we'll have you
back Labor Day when no one's around
that's right good to see you thank you a
minute Nick Swisher on Twitter and
you're on Instagram too yeah at your boy
swish yeah your boy swish yeah hey we're
coming up man I'm trying to get you know
what that's thing like this social media
stuff man it's hard because yeah you
kind of got it you gotta keep you gotta
do it every day
feed the beast feed the beast man so I'm
trying to I'm coming up on 100k that's a
goldmine rich eyes and fans okay I need
you okay need you need you at the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience